[Applaudissements]
nous avons avec le département des
yvelines des liens de confiance et
d'amitié désormais puisque nous partons
depuis 2010 pour paris-nice les yvelines
sont terre de cyclisme pour le haut
niveau
paris-nice le vélodrome à saint-quentin
l'optique des jeux olympiques avec en
plus le bmx et le vtt puis aussi
formidable notamment dans la vallée de
chevreuse pour la pratique du cyclisme
pour tout à chacun
en ce début du mois de janvier 2021 nous
avons moins d'indications de la part des
équipes sur les coureurs qui seront au
départ parce que la pandémie est là
parce que ils n'ont pas pu établir leur
planning de course avec les coureurs qui
seront dans telle ou telle épreuve dès
maintenant et parce que par exemple pour
certaines équipes ne peuvent pas
récupérer aujourd'hui le recours aux
sud-américains ou leurs coureurs qui
sont dans les îles britanniques il
n'empêche que le numéro un mondial prime
aux robes glitch vainqueur du tour
d'espagne vainqueur de l'un des
monuments du canoë du mas amiel et qui a
fait figure de vainqueur du tour de
france m'impute dix jours pour découvrir
paris nice au mois de mars avec lui il y
aura d'autres coureurs de grande qualité
je pense notamment aux
vainqueur du giron tao guegan art
le jeune britannique qui sera là je
pense aussi à jane l'est qui était l'une
des révélations l'australien du giro
également et puis il y aura là les
baroudeurs du type de philippe gilbert
l'ancien champion du monde mais il y
aura quasiment les meilleurs sprinteurs
de la planète
c'est un paris nice qui dans son
organisation ressemblera très
vraisemblablement à celui de l'année
dernière c'était le début de la pandémie
l'année dernière il ya un système de
georges grâce au département de les
yvelines et aux collectivités de tout
parent et nice mais des yvelines nous
avions pu nous adapter il y avait des
choses qui ont changé
3-3 système de jauge différents en
attendant pendant les huit jours de la
course fut une dernière étape qui n'a
pas eu lieu bref nous avons évidemment
plus que l'espoir d'organiser l'épreuve
complète cette année mais avec ces
mesures de gestes barrières de
distanciation le système de bulles bref
nous devrons nous adapter